you've really killed me in the beer
department yeah it requires you to drink
it braise I've been called out hello
Austin and Craig what's up right how's
it going good can we cheers I feel like
we have to yeah this is sitting right
here are necessary cheers to you guys
cheers to southern charm it's great
seeing you how do you feel about this
season so far
I would probably hospitalized if I force
myself to watch it so I'm trying my best
it's not the easiest thing watching you
and your ex break up let's get into the
Niomi of it all I cannot live my life
the way that you live your life you only
focus on the negative let me talk let me
talk I've thought I was going into that
I thought I was a getting back together
meeting and it was turned into being and
never really talking to each other again
almost level meeting I didn't like we
both moved on with our lives but for
some reason it's really tough to see her
say stuff like she's I see that she's
doing like jealous tendencies you have
something me and I feel like it has to
do with thirsty [ __ ]
she's brutal there's no nice way to put
it
it was completely unnecessary for her to
just destroy Payton play it she I mean
Craig you you or the whole cause of it
100%
it was pure jealousy and she unleashed
Janelle page is the door closed there
for a romantic relationship for good I
mean I would say at this point yes not
saying that would ever happen but yeah
if it did it would be in ten years not
right now it looks like she has a new
guy in her life I don't really know
what's going on but I like that dude I
mean Charleston's not big he's a cool
guy and I selfishly want her to have
someone in her life so she stays out of
my life so that I can then do whatever I
want
relationship status for both of you
right now I'm very single very single
bond seems to be ever-changing well
judging by your social media there's
there is a steady lady in your life
right now yeah I love watching you try
that one
is there yeah I don't know will we see
this girl who may or may not be steady
in your life on the show this season I'm
no no no that was later way later but
awesome
other interests is uh turns out to be
quite dramatic or uh yeah controversial
that whole part of our lives when he
starts dating Chelsea's friend it has
not even happened yet it hasn't been
sexual since we broke up so her sneaking
across the hall okay
she got like [ __ ] yeah that I know
you're making me want a drink
a contract I'm gonna get a drink yeah I
don't know how things continue to be
yeah what else is there in our life
happened in it just continues to evolve
earth wild so yeah all right well I'm
excited to watch the rest yeah yes you
guys